bharti rani is well known in her
neighborhood
she stops and talks to other domestic
workers who live nearby
many are now friends but some close
their doors
she's too much of an activist they say
she doesn't mind though
she wants to make sure that other young
women and girls are never afraid
like she was once to speak out against
harassment
she
was only eight years old when she was
sent to work for a rich family
and to live with them without pay it's a
common arrangement in indian cities
which activists say amounts to modern
slavery
harassment and abuse by employers is
common too
and domestic workers often say they
can't afford to speak out at the risk of
losing their jobs
but bharti stresses that it is better to
lose a job with dignity
than to suffer through one without
nansabhat heads of women's rights ngo
she points out that while me two
testimonials occupied mostly digital
spaces
she found similar reactions amongst
bharti and other domestic workers
offline as well they asked women to
share their workplace harassment
experiences through art and writing
and stitched it together on a saree
calling it maybe
which means me too in hindi so when they
displayed the piece
recalls there was a stunned silence they
didn't realize that
you know there are others like them as
well they thought that they were the
only ones
who had experienced sexual harassment at
the world of work it got them to talk
about it
realize that what has happened to them
is
unfair and they can speak and they're
not alone
bharti rani says this isn't just about
her
she wants to ensure that her daughter
grows up watching her mother live with
dignity
[Music]
that she wants her daughter to be
unafraid of the rich
to have a big house herself a
comfortable job
she's confident her daughter can be just
like them
but a much much kinder person
and across the border in pakistan women
have marched across the country
to assert their rights on international
women's day called
locally as aurat march or women's march
it's been an annual feature in the
country for the past three years
women have taken to the streets to
demand equality and a level playing
field in a society notorious for its
patriarchal mindset
in the past these marches have drawn
strong criticism from conservative
elements in the country
and binis javed from dw asia is an
islamabad and was at one of these
nationwide
markets what are pakistani women
marching for
pakistani women are marching for rights
that some in many parts of the world
would consider to be very fundamental
and basic
they're asking for rights such as right
to pursue education to be able to be
to walk on the streets without being
harassed uh the right to marry someone
of their own will um and these
very they're asking they're on the
streets with these very simple and basic
rights
um i've spoken to many men
here in the capital who are uh marching
and they say that they are
against years of suppression and control
and dominance
uh of the society they believe that
pakistan is a deeply patriarchal society
and still um pakistani women cannot
enjoy enjoy the empowerment and the
freedom
that they deserve they're using very
provocative uh slogans very provocative
um and bold uh play cards that show the
hypocrisy of the society
uh they they say they're using a very
controversial slogan mera jason meri
berzy which means my body my choice
uh it was uh uh fiercely criticized last
year also in the march
they're also using them uh the same
slogan this year
uh which uh they believe uh is their
fundamental right
they give they are trying to give the
message um that uh
a woman's body is it's her right right
uh whereas the conservatives and the
yep but how much uh does this march
represent the aspirations of women
across pakistan
videsh i as a reporter have traveled to
many villages in pakistan many small
towns in pakistan i have lived in big
cities and small cities
and there's a stark difference between
urban women and ruler women
but like any other movement in the world
this movement is
has started from the urban centers from
university students from young women
full of activism um and they believe uh
they are also speaking up for the rights
of all women across pakistan
i have read some manifestos i have read
a charter of uh demands of some of the
chapters of the march
and they are clearly are asking for
rights for everyone and i do believe
that the kind of momentum this march has
gained uh in the last couple of years
uh it is the message is spreading across
pakistan
penis jairus from dw asia thank you so
much for that
and of course international women's day
this year comes in the middle of a
raging global pandemic
a pandemic that's impacted women
disproportionately when compared to men
especially when it comes to access to
employment and
child care for instance now we sought
views from women
across the region
[Music]
has particularly impact women briefly
because actually all the human race no
matter their men
or women no matter what country or risk
they are
they are all impacted by this greatly
we are all equally vulnerable perhaps
this is
a moment for us to learn and to cope
a global pandemic like this better the
next time
tonight
foreign
you